mon nom on s'en branle mais qui vient
vos soirées personne connaît mais tout
le monde est invité
bienvenue à coke aux loges
nan mais [ __ ] business a brandi des
choses on parle de gros sous là j'ai
besoin que tu m'a vendu produits
un kilo
pour un prêt du détail ça se présente
pas de fois dans une des dernières fois
qu'on a traité tous les deux j'ai failli
faire de la tension
j'aime pas les problèmes on est en train
de prendre tout pas là encore on va
monter jusqu'en france de la vidéo est
sa mère est la vérité était coiro c'est
pas parce que tu retiens ta merde pour
pas chier tu va l'empêcher de tâches et
le calvaire qu'est ce qui se passe là
est plus qu'un disparu a pu bouger nice
se déplace et pas un prince charmant
saint go est blond doublé d'un agrafes
il ya un truc qu'on dit pas dans le
manuel du parfait dealer mais qd apprend
très vite
tu es tout seul dans ta merde que ce
soit dans la partie c'est aussi contre
70 me d'abord mis ses pas dans son
infinie
son ma fille soit calibre tu en classe
de nous s'appelle l'ena
je paye ma tête tu est libre
klose a dit on livre
mon rêve je le voyais pas sans ma gosse
qui vit par la farine quand tout
s'écroule au fur et à mesure je regarde
ta vie partir en miettes à puissant
champagne aux papilles
allez tous leurs objets d'un autre
capitaine et son équipage vous souhaite
la bienvenue à bord je peux pas te
parler leur attention
nous prévoyons des turbulences durant ce
vol
nous vous remercions d'avoir choisi
notre ligne
vous souhaitons un agréable voyage sur
coco airlines
[Musique]
souhaitez-vous soit à l'argent
je sais pas moi la base line site une
sono mise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]